On April the seventh, 1739,
an English criminal was executed by hanging at the gallows in York.
His crime was stealing three horses, a manhole,
and a gelding from a man named Thomas Creasy of Welton Yorkshire.
The value of these horses with six pounds and 20 shillings,
the criminal has in fact committed many other much more heinous acts,
including highway robberies, burglaries, poachings, numerous assaults,
and even murder it.
Ultimately he was convicted of horse theft and perished age 33 at the end of the
news under normal circumstances.
That would be no reason why we would be talking about this man today,
or even remembering his name,
but then something strange happened almost a hundred years after his death,
a Victorian Nola's named William Harrison,
Ainsworth published a novel called Rockwood,
which went on to become a big success.
Although fictional the story took inspiration from real life events and
characters, including a dashing adventurous and even romantic highway.
Then by the name of Dick Tappin, he became a sensation almost overnight.
People fell in love with Dick tap,
and but few of them realized that they were in Emma's with this idealized
version of him from a novel, not the real person.
The most famous story about the highway men is the legendary 200 mile rides that
he made from London to New York on his trusted horse,
black bass and a single night so that he could give himself an alibi for a crime
that he had committed in London. But you guessed at this bobble, this feat,
if equestrianism came from the novel, not from real life, if it did happen,
the rides may have been done by another Highwayman called John Swift,
Nick Nevison. But for some reason,
what do you means worth decided to credit it to Dick Turpin in Rockwood?
Perhaps he simply liked the name more, regardless of his motivation,
the writer transformed Dick Turpin from a common criminal destined for obscurity
into the most notorious high women of all time.
And today we'll be exploring his story, trying to separate fact from fiction.
Yeah.
Being heavily associated with the English County of York,
Richard Dick Turpin was actually born in Essex and the village of Hempstead in a
place called the blue bell in which still stands to this day.
The date of his birth is a bit more uncertain,
but historical records show that he was baptized on September the 25th, 1705.
Unsurprisingly has only, life is one big mystery.
We only know this at one point,
he entered the butcher trade and became an apprentice before striking out on his
own and possibly moving to London.
He probably tried to operate within the boundaries of the law for a few years.
We're not really sure how long,
but back then being a boat show was a relatively quick way of associating with
criminals,
but that's because one of the most common crimes of the date was poaching.
It was such a problem that the British parliament passed the black act of 1723,
which was described as an act for the more effectual, punishing, wicked,
and evil disposed persons going armed in disguise and doing injuries and
violences do the persons and of his Majesty's subjects.
And for the most speedy bringing the offenders to justice specifically,
the acts was meant to sound target,
get several groups of deer poachers who were active in the forest, snow,
Waltham and Windsor, but it was applied of course,
to anybody else who fit the criteria.
And it became rather notorious and controversial, the large number of crimes,
which were made punishable by death.
It was called the black acts because many of the poachers in Waltham had a habit
of blackening, their faces to disguise themselves.
Dick Tappan probably did not have any dealings with these poachers,
but he did associate himself with the Gregory gang,
also called the Asics gang led by Samuel Gregory.
They also poached among many other crimes, which meant they needed bushes,
willing to buy their illegal mutans Turpin was their man.
We do not know when Turpin became involved with their activities and were also
unsure of when he decided to delete the butcher trade behinds and join up with
the gang full time. It was most likely sometime during the early 1730s,
because there is a mention of the group tapping included in an issue of the
London Gazette from February, 1734, offering a 50 pound reward for that capture.
As by that point,
they will already want it for robberies committed in the counties of Essex,
Middlesex, Kenton, sorry.
The leader Samuel Gregory was described as about five feet,
seven inches high as a scar about an inch and a half long.
And his right cheek is fresh colored,
whereas a Brown wig and is about 23 years old is a Smith or a Feria by trade
to other members of the gang named in the article have that Hanes and Thomas
route.
And finally Dick Tappan was described as a butcher by trade it's all fresh
colored man, very much marks with the small talks, about 26 years of age,
about five feet, nine inches high lived some time ago at wise,
chapel and S did latently lodged somewhere about Milbank Westman stuff.
Whereas a blue gray coat and a light natural wig.
[Inaudible].
To popular belief. The real Dick Tappan was not a lovable Rogan's.
Neither were the people that are associated with there were extremely violent
and had no qualms about threatening beating and torturing the victims who either
fought against them or refuse to surrender their valuables.
By the time surfing became an official part of the Essex gang that already
pretty much moved away from poaching completely and turned towards thievery.
Despite his reputation as a highway man that were actually a few highway
robberies committed at this time,
the Essex gang preferred to target people in their own homes because it was more
likely they would find money that they liked writing farmhouses. Most of all,
because they were remote and quiet and the robbers could take their time to make
sure that they go to everything of value.
The regions surrounding Epping forest stretching between Asics and London was
the main area of operations. During these raids,
the gang often restrained and tortured their victims to get them to reveal where
they had their money. One notorious case was that of Joseph Lawrence,
a 70 year old farmer from edge web seven and other members of the gang beat up
the old man and poured boiling water onto him.
While Samuel Gregory raped one of the maids in another room,
there is one surviving contemporary accounts.
All of the gang inaction published Reed's weekly journal detailing,
a different rate in Lawson. It said on Saturday night,
last about seven o'clock five rogues ends at the house of widow, Shelly.
It Lufton in Essex having pistols and threatened to murder the old lady.
If she would not tell them where our money lay,
which she obstinately refusing for some time,
they threatened to lay her across the fire.
If she did not instantly tell them which she would not do,
but our son being in the room and threatened to be murdered, cried out,
he would tell them if they would not measure his mother and did whereupon,
they went upstairs and took now 100 pounds of silver tankards and other plates
and all manner of household goods.
Afterwards went into the cellar and drank several bottles away,
a little wine and sprawled some meat,
actually relics of a fearless feel while they were doing this.
Two of their gang went to Mr. Terkel was a farmer who rents one end of the
widow's house and robbed him of above 20 pounds.
And then they all went off taking two of the farmers,
horses to carry off their luggage.
The horses were found on Sunday and the following morning and old street and
stayed about three hours in the house. This account was from early February,
1735. And the gang actually did not last for much longer.
Afterwards later that same month authorities captured three members of the
group. Although historical records disagree on the circumstances.
What matters was that one of the criminals, a man by the name of John Wheeler,
confessed to his deeds and informs on the rest of the Essex gang in exchange for
his freedom. The other two men,
John Fields and William Saunders were both found guilty on multiple accounts of
burglary and robbery and was sentenced to death. Days later,
the three more members of the gang were captured. Two of them,
Joseph Rice and Humphrey Walker were also sentenced to death.
While the third Mary Brasier,
the only woman of the group who acted as their fence was sentenced to penal
transportation to the colonies.
Several other members were arrested and executed in the months that followed.
This included the leader, Samuel Gregory,
who was found guilty of rape among other charges and sentence death.
The Essex gang was officially over his only two members were still alive.
Thomas Bowden and Dick Tatton
And ends up in stuck together.
And they switched the modus operandi from raiding thumb houses to the crime that
made Dick tap and famous highway rubbery. However,
they eventually decided to disband later that same year and Bowden might've been
apprehended soon after for counterfeiting turpines actions during the year 1736,
a big mystery, but it seems they continued preying on travelers.
And at one point joined forces with another highway,
man named Tom King sometimes identified as Matthew King,
according to one contemporary accounts written by a man named Richard Bass.
The two highway men struck a partnership after turpine tried robbing King
mistaking him for a gentlemen.
This new collaboration didn't last long because in May, 1737,
Tom King was shot and killed possibly by tarping himself.
We say possibly because there is debate over who fired the fatal round.
The whole reason why Richard Bayes wrote a bio on Tappan was because he was
there for this event is part of a policy that's went out to apprehend the
Highwayman.
And he is the one who claims that Turpin shot his partner by mistake King
immediately drew a pistol, which he to Mr. Bass's breasts.
But it luckily flashed in the pan upon which King struggling to get out his
other. It twisted rounds in his pockets and he could not tap.
Then who was waiting not far off on horseback hearing a skirmish came up when
King cried out, Dick shoot him,
or we are taken by gods at which incident turban fired his pistol,
MIS Mr. Bays and shot King in two places who cried out Dick, you have kills me,
which tap hearing. He rode away as hard as he could.
The reason why this account is dubious is because others have later concluded
that Bayes had embellished his version of events.
And so as he may have been the one who actually found the lethal shot,
it is possible.
He did it after King had already surrendered or when he had his back turns,
which is why bays decided to pass the blame on to the other high women.
While this death may or may not be attributable to Dick Turpin,
there is no doubt that the next one was cold-blooded murder after King's demise
turbine decided to delay Lou for a while in his old hideaway Epping forest.
But on may the fourth, 1737, a forest keeper named Thomas Morris,
Johns deposed him. The last I tried to apprehend the criminal old,
but he was shot dead by Turpin. Once the murder was discovered,
a raw proclamation was issued, which offered a ransom of 200 pounds.
The Tibetans capture a proclamation that was included in William Ainsworth's
introduction to Rockwood.
And it said it's having been represented to the King that Richard Devon did on
Wednesday. The 4th of May last barber Asley murdered Thomas Morris sevens to
Henry Thompson.
One of the keepers of Epping forest dins committed to other notorious felonies
and robberies.
Now London is majesty is pleased to promises most gracious pardons,
if any of his accomplices and they reward of 200 pounds to any person or persons
that shall discover him.
So as he may be apprehended and convicted to up in was born at Baxter and Essex
is about 30 by trade, a butcher about five feet, nine inches,
high Brown complexion, very much boxed with smallpox.
His cheekbones broad his face thinner towards the bottom. His bizarre, short,
pretty uprights and broad about the shoulders.
Also notable in the proclamation is the fact that it gives to up in his place of
birth as faxed it instead of Hampstead like other historical records do,
but this might have simply been a mess
Bouncy out on him,
dicked up and decided that it would probably be a good idea to leave Epping
forest and go somewhere where he would be less recognizable.
So he traveled up North to York.
He posed as a respectable horse trader named John Palmer,
but he did not change his ways very much.
He have turned down the violence of his crimes for going robberies and
burglaries in favor of horse and castle theft.
He moved around frequently between Lincoln Cher and Yorkshire counties stealing
from the first and then selling his ill-gotten goods in the seconds.
The strategy worked well for over a year and might have continued to work well.
We're not the terpenes bad temper. One day in October 17, 38,
he shot a rooster in the street in broad daylight.
We're not sure why maybe he was angry and wanted to take his frustrations out on
something, or maybe he was bored and thought it would be funny either way.
Local man named John Robinson saw him and his confronted Tappan who then
threatened to shoot him as well. If he did not leave the rise, man, complied,
but went and told the authorities who arrested the man.
They knew as John Panera and sends him to the Beverly House of correction at
this point, nobody yet knew the true identity of the person that in custody,
but just by taking a closer look at his business,
it became clear to authorities that John Palmer was not exactly an upstanding
citizen. He tried to claim that he used to be a butcher in Lincolnshire,
but fell into heavy debt.
So he ran away in an attempt to start a new life in New York.
This story didn't hold water though into quick chats with the authorities in the
neighboring County revealed.
But John Palmer was suspected of committing multiple thefts of livestock in the
area. The case took a more serious turn at that point.
His horse theft was a capital crime back then.
So John Palmer was transferred to York castle to a wages trial.
It looked like dicta then would seem to be headed for the gallows regardless of
whether or not the world was aware of his identity. However,
the authorities did discover who John Palmer actually was and what has to be
considered.
One of the earliest documented cases of forensic pathology in February, 1739.
Southerner is a letter to his brother-in-law identified in historical records is
[inaudible] who lived back in assets and Hempstead's and had married Tevin
system. The lesser does not survive and its contents are unknown,
but it is likely that the highway men wanted his family to prepare some people.
They trusted to act as a character witness for the fictional John Palmer at his
trial. Unfortunately, if it's open, that was no Melman.
Back then the lessons arrived to the local post office and the recipients went
there to pick them up and set, to pay the postdoc charges.
When retinol was informed of the latter,
he said he didn't know who John Palmer was and he didn't correspond with anyone
in New York. So he refused.
To pay the postage. Maybe this was true, or.
Maybe he did realize that the letter was from Turpin and he simply didn't want
to get involved with his troubles either way.
Ronald did not take charge of the letter.
Even more unfortunate for Turpin was that another person definitely did
recognize you sent the letter. He was another local named James Smith.
And in years past he used to teach type in at school and knew his handwriting
Smith went to a magistrate named Thomas studying and informed him of this fact.
Since the last time I paid the postal charges and took possession of the letter,
reading it in its entirety,
Smith became even more convinced that Dick Durbin was the man who wrote it.
And he was then asked,
traveled to your castle to make a positive idea of the Highwayman.
He did that since he testified on February the 23rd,
1739 in front of yoga authorities that the man showed to him as John Palmer was
in fact, Richard Turpin and no other person.
This revelation changed the complexity of the trial.
And there were sometimes arguments in the County over whether Turpin should be
tried in Yorkshire or London. In the end,
this case was heard of the Yorker sizes since all of his crimes carried the
death penalty anyway, but he was never charged with the murder of Thomas Morris,
the forest keeper,
or the numerous robberies and assaults that he had committed seven witnesses.
What called against dicta up in the none in his favor.
His story was that he had purchased the horses from an inky Burnett Hackinson
gold John White ads. But since that man could not be found,
he really didn't have any evidence to defend himself to nobody surprised the
jury found tap in guilty without even leaving the court.
And the sentenced him to death
Execution was carried out about two weeks after the trial on April the seventh,
1739,
a local named Thomas Gill attended both the legal proceedings and the execution,
and then published a pamphlet about what he saw so well that Tim tell us how the
events unfolded the morning before Tappin's execution. He gave three pounds,
10 shillings amongst five men who want to follow the court,
his mourners with hat, bans and gloves and gave gloves and hat battens.
Do several persons more.
He also left a gold ring into pairs of shoes and clogs to a married woman.
It bro,
it was acquainted with this over here at the same time acknowledged he had a
wife and child of his own.
He was carried in a cost to the place of execution on Saturday,
the 7th of April, 1739 with John Steed condemns also for horse stealing.
He behaved himself with amazing assurance and bowed to the spectators.
As he passed. It was a remarkable that as he mounted the ladder,
his right leg trembles on which he stamped it down with an air and with
undaunted courage looked round about him.
And after speaking now half an hour to at the top,
someone threw himself off the ladder and expired in about five minutes to bins.
Body was left to swing for half the day before being cut down and capture to
local Tavern in salt. The following morning,
when it was given a church burial afterwards, he experienced a brief revival.
As his remains were immediately targeted by body snatches.
The so-called resurrection men who dug up fresh corpses and sold them to medical
schools for anatomy studies. But again, we'll let kill tell the story.
The grave was dug very deep and the persons whom he appointed his mourners as
above mentioned, took all possible care to secure the body, not withstanding,
which on Tuesday morning, about three o'clock.
Some persons were discovered to be moving off the body, which they had taken up.
And the malt having got sent where it was carried due and suspecting.
It was to be an atomized,
went to a garden in which it was deposited and brought away the body through the
streets of the city and the sort of Trump almost naked being only laid on a
board,
covered with some straw and carried on Forman's shoulders and buried it in the
same grave. Having first filled the coffin with stacked lime.
Now that was the ends of ticks up in the man,
but only the beginning of Dick tap and the legends.
Thanks to people like Thomas Gill, Richard bays, and most of all,
William Ainsworth, his feats, both real and imagined.
We'd get told and retold in pamphlets, books,
penny dreadfuls plays and even movies helping Dick Turpin secure his position as
the King of the highway men. So I really hope you found that video. Interesting.
If you did, please do hit that thumbs up button below.
Don't forget to subscribe and thank you for watching.
Yeah.